right now Arkansas is definitely the
NRA's favorite state because Clarksville
high school in Arkansas is going to be
arming 20 teachers administrators and
staff yeah they're giving them 1100
bucks each to purchase a handgun in a
holster they're gonna get training and
we will have armed teachers in the
school this is completely bonkers but
let's talk about it anyway what a great
learning environment what what like what
a terrific way to prime your brain for
new information yeah the constant fear
of a gun violence now I you know I you
could argue that those kids are already
living under the constant threat of gun
violence but but it at least could be
wait how could you argue that what what
can people do break into school okay
yeah but at least you could think of
that as theoretical these kids know that
there are actual guns in the schools
with their teachers who they don't
necessarily trust yeah I was a teacher
for two years little-known random fact I
was a high school teacher for two years
and I was a teacher at at-risk school
where there some of the kids had
actually been in that school because of
gun violence specifically so there was a
little bit of a heightened threat
because some of these kids have like the
ankle bracelet some of these kids a lot
of them came from you know homes with
violence in them the first thing I can
say is as a teacher you are so
overworked and underpaid and stressed
out and have such long hours and there's
so much chaos going on in a high school
classroom even if you run your classroom
very well and I feel like because I was
yeah I was pretty young when I was
teaching the kids kind of had a little
bit of trust with me that they don't
necessarily have as the teachers get
older even in my room and I felt was
very functional there was always just
you know 45 kids to manage and a lesson
plan to get out and and who hasn't eaten
today and so many different things that
a teacher is responsible for got to add
it managing and caring of a firearm on
top of that is just completely
inappropriate to put on top of a
teacher's job or they already have so
many jobs to do number one right number
two this program cost about $50,000 per
teacher in the end to you know to arm
them to train them all this stuff it's
estimated it's costing the state of
Arkansas but $50,000 per teacher yeah
why couldn't you if they're gonna arm
teachers take $50,000 for one or two or
three potential security guards if you
do want to introduce guns to school
that's a whole nother argument should
even security guards have them why not
have a trained professional who knows
what to do with guns they're you know
they're in case anything could happen
rather than a teacher who really I don't
care if you give them a couple hundred
hours of training that's not their
primary duty what they're focused on
third thing is teachers or people and
there's human error so teachers do have
personal relationships with kids there's
been at least I'm telling you here
teacher at least one student has
threatened you and said I'm gonna kill
your ass
yeah it just adds the human element of
it what's the teacher's excuse then Oh a
kid came to school today and said that
he was gonna kill me because I gave him
a bad grade I had to shoot him because I
had to shoot him so the human error
there and then learned and then the
lawsuits that'll happen when a teacher
finally doesn't use the firearm right or
when it can get to a hold of one I mean
even if the teachers holstering and how
do you know what kids not going to grab
it so let's let's take it to that place
because we can talk about it in theory
but the logistical nightmare alone so
should the teacher have the gun on the
Maltin should it be in a locked drawer
and then if it is well it's probably too
late
very soon precisely so and I feel like
the teachers because this isn't a
mandatory thing it's voluntary and the
the the teachers that are gonna opt in
are the ones who have these nutjob
fantasies where like you know a gunman
is coming into the school but there they
got ice cold water running through their
veins and they're just like they're
gonna be you know what I mean like I'm
gonna take this guy out which by the way
no you're not like ever is so it's it's
gonna be these like gun happy people
with like vigilante you know hero
fantasies yeah and who are we're more
likely to shoot and so that that worries
me did it the the thing that really
bothers me though is that like
unfortunately this is the logical end of
our gun culture you know what I mean
like barring some sort of massive shift
in our cultural consciousness this is
just the way it's going to get well
that's the has one that's the sick part
remember when Wayne LaPierre the
president of the NRA we remember when he
said I've gone in every school and only
a good guy with a gun can stop a bad guy
with a gun and we were all that was
right after Newtown and everyone was
like oh this guy's bonkers well now we
are only what six eight months of after
that or at most ten months and already
it's it's begun
yeah so and we couldn't pass meaningful
gun legislation a couple months ago so
it's like does this all just slip early
a slippy slide slope into arm every
teacher and have every teacher start to
say it's my right to feel safe at my job
to carry a gun at school and it's
completely inappropriate for any teacher
I don't care what you're saying unless
you're off-duty thing has to learn to
train and become a security guard if
you're a teacher you have no business
having a gun on you while you're trying
to educate a classroom that's a complete
separate job the security and safety of
the classroom while you are in charge of
the general safety and making sure
nothing bananas is going on in your room
to add that on top of it it just means
that either you do have a vigilante
problem or you feel so unsafe in your
classroom that maybe you want to
reevaluate your position of the teacher
anyway is there any way to reverse any
of this though if we're going down that
route that's how it gets reversed a
teacher had goes through it they can't
get shot that just get yours all the
time I don't know I I don't think then
that person will get written off as a
crazy yeah and then I'll be like well
then we need to have background checks
for the teachers you know it's
unconstitutional I have background
checks for the teachers and let it know
unfortunately we're going we're going
down this road it's a bummer I the I
want to know who's gonna be the first to
like shoot into the air to quiet down
their classroom right you know me
because that I feel like will happen on
the third day of school right that's
what it seems exactly that that has to
happen here unfortunately you're gonna
arm these people if something has to
happen they're not doing it so nothing
will happen something will happen
someone's gonna shoot they're gonna
shoot through the roof and then just
kick kill the kid upstairs like it just
it does not end well it's I hated the
fact that when the Newtown parents were
were kind of front and center when they
were we were trying to pass some kind of
sensible gun legislation pro-gun people
were saying well you're just that was an
emotional appeal that was that was a
there was a weak emotional appeal you
know to people's you know it's sympathy
or whatever yet somehow this ridiculous
BS about like a good guy with a gun
being the only person who can stop a bad
guy with a gun which by the way is Jett
appeals to your
lizard brain just as much not more
somehow has made it possible to have leg
now now armed teachers at school in
Arkansas you're right it also is the
same emotional knee-jerk reaction
because the same the way that they're
saying that they were using them you
know the families in Connecticut to
appeal to you like oh we can't have guns
it is the exact same knee-jerk reaction
to the other side of like Oh kids got
shot arm everyone like well that's the
thing everyone doesn't mind the
emotional appeal they just want it to be
their emotions that you share with them